it's 40 watts it's a quite a powerful
laser yes for more than 50 years Japan
has been at the forefront of big physics
creating experiments of such size and
the mission that they need to be seen to
be believed
my name is Davide Castel Vickie and I am
one of nature's physics reporters in
this series I will be traveling to Japan
to visit three of its flagship
experiments delving inside Japan's big
physics Cara started construction in
2012 it was built to do one thing detect
gravitational waves so gravitational
waves like wobbles of space-time they
happen when mass moves but usually
gravitational waves are very very small
and we are trying to catch those
space-time wobbles and we are building
the detector hoyt these bubbles in
space-time were originally predicted by
Albert Einstein and they were first
discovered a century later in 2015 by a
pair of detectors called LIGO based in
the United States but Japanese
physicists also have been developing the
technology for decades and now kagra
is the most advanced gravitational wave
detector in the world it is being built
underneath mount econo outside the small
town of kameoka
Kagura is the latest addition to the
Kamioka Observatory a powerhouse buried
deep under the mountain I got a tour of
the Kagura facility from Shinji Miyake
as it neared completion on the way into
kagra we had to clean our equipment and
take off our shoes there's a lot of
taking your shoes off in Japan it is a
custom when entering a building but for
scientific facilities like Kagura it
also serves the purpose of keeping the
space clean free of contaminants that
could affect the experiments the cavern
that houses the corner unit is the heart
of the Kagura detector it is filled with
towering vacuum tanks cryogenic systems
and optical Hardware Paul encasing clear
plastic curtains to keep out the dust
every parking tanks are housed in green
dunes so how does all of this measure
bubbles in space-time well that all
starts with a laser the data is set
inside this soundproof room in order to
detect any sound noise from outside to
inside and inside this soundproof room
there is a super clean room order data
the Green River is the chakra swamp if
there is no human
human activity inside the laser
generated in this room will be used to
detect gravitational waves it travels
through a complicated series of lenses
and mirrors to finesse focus and shape
it before it's split into and sent
hurtling down the arms of kaga and that
is where we headed next the two arms
each extend exactly three kilometers
away from the central hole the tubes
carrying the lasers are held at high
vacuum even in an electric vehicle it
takes us 10 minutes to do what the laser
does in microseconds reach the end of
the wire arm of kaga once it reaches the
ends the laser hits a mirror and bounces
back then another mirror bouncing back
again and so on the laser light bounces
back and forth hundreds of times before
finally the two beams are recombined and
sent into the detector the waveforms of
the two beams will align perfectly and
cancel each other out that is unless one
of the arms has been slightly stretched
or squeezed by a passing gravitational
wave if that happens then the
wavelengths will no longer line up and
the signal will be detected Kagura is
built to sense many skill stretches in
its arms less than the diameter of a
proton to do so it's mirrors must remain
perfectly still that is part of why
Kagura was built underground to reduce
the interference from seismic wave
activity but beyond that there is some
pretty mind-boggling technology to help
recycling mirrors signal deciphering
mean
our house in this and the D sound
button thanks this is suspended from
disparate mass and the mass D is also
suspended from this and this is also
suffering from this time the disease
other gravitational wave detectors like
LIGO or virgo is counterpart in Italy
also have suspension systems to keep
their mirrors and lenses still but
Kagura goes one step further its
cryogenic so other groups like advanced
Riga and what was beautiful didn't
introduce the cryogenics technologies
but our kagra project was started about
20 years later from the advanced LIGO
and the beauties for we introduced the
up-to-date technologies cooling the
mirrors decreases the tiny thermal
vibrations of the mirror itself reducing
the noise in the laser and increasing
the sensitivity of the detector to stay
cold the mirrors must be made of a
material that easily disperses heat
sapphire and cryogenic mirrors have to
be supported by cryogenic suspension
systems kagura's cryogenic systems were
developed over two decades at the
university of tokyo and they are one of
the detectors biggest advances the
challenge is to keep the mirrors cold
without transmitting any vibrations back
into them we couldn't go inside the work
area as we didn't reach the appropriate
clean rating but taka yukita Maru agreed
to take my phone inside this gave us a
closer look inside the vacuum chamber
that will host the mirrors suspension
system
[Music]
kagra plans to join LIGO and Virgo for
the latest observing run which started
in April of 2019 with the additional
power of kagra scientists will be able
to detect more events and better
triangulate the sources of gravitational
waves gravitational wave astronomy
cannot be done only one or two detectors
so two levels and one vehicle have very
good sauce pointing but they still have
some blind spots depending on the source
direction adding the four detector we
will have almost no blind spot and there
is one event that everyone is crossing
their fingers to detect we want to be
very lucky to have the supernova event
which will give us not only
gravitational waves but also hopefully
in yutori law but we need to be lucky I
want them to wait for Kagura and get
online so I hope to do it soon and I
will feel better in the next episode we
head to the other side of Japan to
Tsukuba and KEK Japan's very own version
of CERN we will see an experiment that
could blow open the field of particle
physics
[Music]